[Music]
hello I feel like we should talk about
the major sporting event that is on at
the moment
Wimbledon I'm entered the tennis I like
the female tennis but I hate what people
say about it whenever the female tennis
on it's always oh my god that noises
those women make when they play tennis
it makes it sound like they're having
sex really and I think you might be
doing sex wrong if you're having sex
with a woman and she's going let her go
okay she's not enjoying that stop it
before the police there's a crime being
committed that is the wrong type of
backhand sir from my experience if women
were to make the same noises they make
during sex or playing tennis this is
what tennis would sound like
Shh you're gonna wake my dad up
seriously are you nearly finished no no
in my hair goods good yeah well actually
talk about the the soccer I really
enjoying I love the world cup i love the
xbox game as well the new xbox on it
it's got a microphone and a camera and
you can give instructions to the game
using your voice they make a
substitution change to this formation
it's amazing but it does have one
negative I was playing on it and you get
messages from the board of the team that
you control saying good job what you're
doing amazing we really like you I don't
get these messages I get messages saying
we do not appreciate the way you are
conducting yourself we expect something
better from a manager in your position
no I'm confused by this and then the day
of the Cup final I was fired from a
computer game that is a new law for me
you can't fire me I own you see what my
thing so I may not like to find out
there was a bug with the game and the
reason genuinely why I was fired from
this game it's because the microphone is
always on any time I swore in real life
the Xbox registered that grasped me up
and then fired me in the game that is a
genuine feature I went online I
complained in EA Sports came out and
said this well we pride ourselves on
making our games is realistic impossible
and if you were to conduct yourself in
that way as an actual manager you would
probably be fired that's a good point EA
Sports I can't argue with that
where my problem lies is with the double
standards for example he fired me for
swearing yet you had no problem when I
paused the game to masturbate but that
was just commitment to the team for you
I was getting into it so I laughed I
went to the other version of
single-player we control one player I
went playing him went in the Box got
slightly tackled caught panelling great
stack top missed the panel eat Wayne
[ __ ] referee blew his whistle came over
red carded me sent my character off the
pitch were either have to watch the rest
of the match that I'm no longer playing
this is a real feature in an actual game
Joe awkward is when your friends come
run to your house and they're like hey
can we please feed Lucknow I'm bond for
three games so uh so I'm single I like
being single I have tinder I love tinder
if you don't what tinder is it's an
application for the phone all right
where it gives you pictures of people of
the opposite sex in the nearby area and
if you don't like each other
swipe left if you do like each other
he's right right it's both like each
other
opens up a conversation then maybe you
can meet up and get down to it the
reason I like tinder it's good before
tinder I had to guess how many women
didn't want to sleep with me but now
thanks to tender it'll send less
directly to my pocket I am curious know
more you can even change the distance so
I can now find out how many women in a
particular room want nothing to do with
me
technology's come far guys I know get
annoyed whenever I go in the internet
like on the porn websites they're like
local [ __ ] in your area want to do you
know they don't I've checked thoroughly
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you